study sound waves Paranormal Activity so  you don't believe it go so real I spent  my entire career proving they're not I  am doing a story on the abandoned subway  station well the fact that people say  it's haunted yeah that's why they call  it the dough station have you been down  there  there's an area it's at the farthest end  of this station sound that's below the  threshold of human hearing it can be  felt people think that the frequency  opens up some sort of portal to the  other side  oh I didn't mean to scare you nobody's  supposed to be here you ever seen  anything down here the station's  built on potter's field potter's field  was a great  you